hi i'm alex i'm a tasty producer and i
love trying random kitchen gadgets today
i'm going to be testing and reviewing
the dash rapid egg cooker i'm going to
be testing three different kinds of egg
preparations a poached egg a boiled egg
and an omelet i'm excited
let's crack this thing open
okay we got some ooh
get cooking good looking
geez there's lots of instructions on
this thing so it looks like it has like
a little dome top some more um pieces
inside here let's open this all up so we
got like our little trays for the eggs
i'm assuming this does feel a little
small though i don't know what kind of
egg you're putting in here what is this
an egg tray for ants i'm assuming you
would put water in here and this would
heat up but like a minimal amount of
water so then it kind of steams
everything you're cooking but maybe we
should just read the instructions should
i oh should i read these warnings note
do not place the lid in the locked
position when the appliance is in use
maybe because you need to be able to
wrap it
i put it in the locked position i
haven't broken it yet and hopefully it
lives up to all its crack to be
we're going to get started with poached
eggs now poached eggs are notoriously
hard to make so we'll see how this goes
use oil to grease the poaching tray you
break an egg into each section of the
poaching tray fill water up to the
omelet poached mark
and pour into the heating plate
so now we're going to put our egg tray
on this the
top
right on there i'm not going to lock it
because it said not to lock it and i'm
scared why
plug it in plug it in
oh and now we have to press the button
are you ready
we're lit
i don't know how long this is supposed
to take before the buzzer goes off so
i'm just going to start a timer but
things are already starting to happen i
mean
the lid is starting to cloud up there is
a little vent on top here for
hot steam it says so we are essentially
steaming our eggs which
isn't really classic to a poached egg
it's starting to get white over the top
of the yolks here's the thing though
it's not round like it's supposed to be
it's more of like an oval
half moon
overall i'd say this hasn't saved too
much
[Music]
that was so cute
okay
that was about six minutes total
oh my gosh
these are overcooked there's a little
bit of like water that i'm kind of
draining off of this okay i'm just gonna
try to like slide one of these off here
oh
well look at her
and then for a little color
i'm gonna top with some chives
we're ready to try it
so you can tell what i made probably
eggs benedict yeah oh oh nice okay
yo so looks can be deceiving it tastes
good it's almost like a boiled egg i
would say that the egg itself is a
little tougher than a poached egg should
be i think this gets it close if you
were to give this poached egg a letter
grade what would you give it c minus
because it's not porched yeah it's not
posh i would agree i expect round prompt
soft portrait yeah all right thanks ryan
thank you although i gave you food so
you should be thanking me oh thank you
thank you for the delicious meal you're
welcome
all right on to the next so we're gonna
do our boiled eggs hopefully they taste
good and hopefully we can use them to
make some deviled eggs i assume that
we're just going to be using our boiling
tray because it seems like perfectly
fitted for
yup but let me still read the
instructions pierce the larger end of
the egg with the attached pin at the
bottom of the measuring cup okay
so we've got a pin
oh geez
so there's a sharp pin on the end of the
measuring cup i'm worried that i never
noticed that before
just gonna give that a little pierce
i'm worried i'm gonna break it i only i
went as far as like i can oh oh there we
go well now we have a total of six we
can cook at one time which is pretty
nice
i'm just gonna
you have to press a little bit hard i
need to put our handle in here we're
able to like pick it up nicely
oh interesting so this cup has a line
for soft medium and hard for deviled
eggs they tend to use more of like a
harder yolk so i'm gonna go for the hard
okay so i'm gonna pour this right in
here again and we're gonna put our cute
little boiling tray right on there
point it upwards
i'm gonna put our lid on
oh
there it goes and now we wait
is it much faster than actually just
boiling an egg maybe here's the point
you don't have to wait for your water to
heat up which takes a while i assume
this is gonna hit around 11 minutes
10 30. maybe you could
gets me every time
oh i'm just gonna transfer these into
our cold water so that they can stop
cooking for some reason smells like
pancakes you know actually it's peeling
fairly well it feels firm feels exactly
like a hard-boiled egg
some water legit just squirted through
that little hole wow i'm really going to
smell like eggs up there
so now to make our deviled eggs i am
just going to cut each of these in half
so now i'm just going to dump all of our
yolks into
this bowl you can also play up on the
flavors you could like throw a little
jalapeno in there you can do some bacon
i'm gonna mix it with about three
tablespoons of mayonnaise a couple of
teaspoons of sweet pickle relish dijon
mustard then i'm gonna add a little bit
of salt
some pepper this is a massive pepper
grinder a little bit of cayenne just for
an added kick i'm just gonna mix this up
real good with a fork transfer it to a
piping bag
almost there so now for a little added
extra color i'm going to top these with
a little bit of paprika and then lastly
with some of our chives i can't wait to
eat them these look good
so katie actually has one of these egg
cookers at home yes so we could call her
an expert
so you use this a lot i like all the
time but mostly my husband because he
loves hard-boiled eggs cheers cheers
little double leg cheers
mmm mmm
nice perfect so have you ever used like
the other cooks on it well the medium
does it really does do pretty well i
think oh it does okay well that's
awesome what letter grade would you give
to our eggs a plus plus boss
i heard it here from our expert
all right so last but not least we are
gonna make an omelette so i'm just gonna
make a basic omelette with a few of my
favorite veggies and then we'll get to
rapid cooking so we're pouring it up to
our omelette line which is the same
exact line as the poached line okay so
i'm gonna put it right on our heating
tray which is a little dirty might i add
so i'm gonna grease our little dish
again whisk the eggs in a separate bowl
before you put them in an omelette bowl
i wonder if it says how many eggs you're
supposed to use whisk one to two eggs
i'm gonna do two eggs so i'm just gonna
give this a whisk
add a little salt
a little pepper
green onions red bell pepper
some spinach
wow so healthy oh and then i'm gonna add
some bacon and cheese
so a little bit of cooked bacon
a little bit of shredded cheddar cheese
that is a jam-packed omelet now i'm
gonna pour this all right in our tray
that fit pretty well once again i'm
gonna put the lid on our cooker all
right we're ready to go
[Music]
double double rapid boiling trouble
it's turning white ish we're essentially
making like an egg patty
rather than a classic omelette if it
tastes like an omelette i'm not going to
complain
oh
it's growing in a weird way
it's coming out of the side a little
[Music]
smells good it seems
seems very loose let's just try it
[Music]
it's oozing i don't think it's raw egg
like initially thought i think it's
water it collects some of that
condensation
and it makes for more of like a watery
omelet let's see how it tastes
if you can get around the
wetness
it's not that bad is this an omelette
no it's possible that you weren't
supposed to fill it with anything but
who wants an omelette with no filling it
doesn't say that you can't put anything
in there but the picture is
of just x i'm gonna give this a d
all right we did it overall i'd say this
was sort of a mixed experience did the
dash rapid egg cooker do its job it did
a job all in all if you like boiled eggs
a lot this could be good for you it's
pretty easy to use it's quick
and
it's pretty cute if you make any of
these recipes let me know you know where
to find me and comment down below on
what you want us to review next
dash ref will you do the dash rapid with
me can you teach me a game
dash
[Music]